ก็
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีน้องเรียมสวัสดีครับท่าน
ผู้เรียนทุกคนเย้นักเรียนออกมาวันนี้มัน
เจอกันมาเรียนภาษาไทยกับนายช่องคอม
เปลี่ยน Small ไทยนะครับกับชายที่แล้วก็
น้องเตรียมค่ะโอเคโอเคอ้าวันนี้ครับวัน
นี้วันนี้เดี๋ยวนะพี่ขอเวลาแป๊บเดียว
อ้าวแป๊บนึงนะครับเห็นนะเพียงที่
ซื้อหน้าตอนนี้พี่ตี้กำลังกำลังให้นัก
เรียนรอรอหน้าน้องเรียมก็รอ
แป๊บหนึ่งโอเคแค่ตอนนี้ตี้หาหาอะไรคะฮ่าๆ
ปีหาเมาส์หามเอาอันใหญ่ตอนนี้เป็น
อันใหญ่แล้วแค่เมาใหญ่ค่ะวันนี้ครับวัน
นี้เรามาเรียนกันวันอะไรครับวันนี้
วันนี้
อาทิตย์
หอวันนี้วันอาทิตย์ใช่ไหมครับวันอาทิตย์
วันอาทิตย์
วันอาทิตย์นี้
อาทิเปียตีหาไม่เจอตอนนี้หาเจอแล้วโอเคๆ
วันอาทิตย์ใน of  R วันอาทิตย์วันที่วัน
ที่เท่าไหร่ครับ
วันที่
28 วันที่ 28
นะโอเควันอาทิตย์ที่ 28 แล้วเดือนอะไร
ครับ
เดิมพฤศจิกายนเดือนนี้เดือน
พฤศจิกายนว้าว 5 เดือนพฤศจิกายนแล้วปีนี้
ครับปีนี้ปีคศอะไรครับ
ปีคศ 2000
4  21  5 ได้ครับข้อ 2021 ว้าวแล้วปีพต
อะไรครับ
พ.ต.
2564 ใช่ครับ
แล้ววันนี้ครับตอนนี้ที่เรามาเรียนกันตอน
นี้ตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วครับ
ตอนนี้ครับตอนนี้ 8:00 น
8:00 น
10 นาทีอ้าโอเค
08:10 น
อาร์อาร์วันนี้วันอาทิตย์มีเรื่องอะไรมา
คุยกับนักเรียนครับวันนี้
วันนี้เขาอากาศหนาวมากให้อากาศหนาวนี่
เพียงตีใส่ใส่เอาเสื้อกันหนาว
ขอหน้าใส่เหรียญก็ใส่หมวก
น้อ
ใส่หมวดหาเพราะว่าหนาวใช่ไหม
ฮ่าๆๆใช่ค่ะแล้วเรียมก็มีน้ำมูก
มีน้ำมูกนะครับน้ำมูกก็คือ
อันนี้จมูก
มีน้ำมูก
เม็ดหมูคอมข้อ 5 เพราะว่าหนาวใช่ไหม
[เพลง]
เตรียมก็ไม่รู้ว่าเหลี่ยมแพ้อ๋อ
แท้
แพ้หาแพ้แพ้เป็นแบบไหนครับเป็นยังไงครับ
แท้คืออะไร
บางคนและก็แพ้ขนสัตว์อ๋ออ๋อ
แพ้
เวลาแพ้แพ้ก็เป็นไงครับชุดตามนะครับเจ้า
ตามอ๋อแพ้ก็มีน้ำมูกเหมือนเดียมมีน้ำมูก
ก็แพ้
[เพลง]
ที่ทำโอ้
โอเคแพ้อา
แล้วก็มีจามด้วย
ว่าจำได้ไหม
ahh จามโอเคจ้าตามเวลาตามก็นี่ตาปิดหน้า
อ่ะจุ
จามโอเคจะจุกหน้าแพ้ขอนักเรียนแพ้อะไรนะ
คะเหมือนอันนี้
แมวอาหารแมวมีขนเหตุผล 5 มีคน
เราก็มีน้ำมูก
มูกตาม
ห้างเพราะว่าแพ้อ๋อขนแมว
แล้วมีอะไรบ้างครับมีอะไรบ้างที่เอ่อเรา
จะแพ้ครับอ่า
มีหลายอย่างมากๆค่ะหลายอย่างที่เราจะแพ้
ใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะเย้แฮปปี้เคยเห็นคนที่กิน
แล้วมี
คันคันๆเขาแบบนี้คันคันๆเพราะว่าแผลใช่
ไหมแผล
ถ้ากินกินแล้วแผลเราเรียกว่าแพ้อาหารใช่
ไหมแพ้อาหารอาหาร
ร้านอาหารที่กินเข้าไปมีอาหารอะไรบ้างที่
กินเข้าไปแล้วแผลครับ
เตรียมเคยเห็นหลายๆคนครับแท้แพ้อาจารย์
ทะเลอ๋อ
กินอาหารทะเลแล้วแผลขอกินอาหารทะเลแล้ว
คัน
คันใช่ไหมคันน้อ
ไม่สบายสบาย
โอเคนี่ไหมครับอันนี้ไหมพี่เอารูปอาหาร
ทะเลอาหารทะเลอาหารทะเลมีอะไรบ้างครับใน
รูปนี้มีอะไรบ้างครับ
มีปลาหมึกหมอปลาหมึกนี่ปลาหมึกก็แพ้นะ
ครับ
ระเบิดตามอื่นแล้วคันเออพี่อาร์ตี้เบียร์
ฟรีกินได้เพียงตี้ไม่คันอ่ะเนื้อหาชาย
ครับน้องเรียมเรียมขออ่ะหน้าเพื่อตีมั้ย
แพ้ใช่ไม่แพ้ห่ากอล์ฟกินปลาหมึกได้ที่ไหน
ขอเรียนกล้องอ๋ออ๋อ
ฮือๆแล้วมีอะไรอีกครับในรูปนี้ที่มีเวลา
กินแล้วจะแผลอาหารทะเลเพื่อนิ่งหน้าคิด
ว่างกุ้งเหมือนกันใช่กุ้งเออมีบางคนกิน
กินกุ้งแล้วคันขันกินไม่ได้แผลหน้า
เฮียตี้ไม่แพ้พี่กินหมดยินได้
อ้าเนาะแท้ไหมกุ้งได้ไม่แถพุ่งได้อ้ะ
เฮียตี้เพี้ยนติรู้รู้ว่าครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋แท้
กุ้งคู่เอกกินกุ้งไม่ได้อ่ะอยากกินกุ้ง
แล้วคัน
คัน
R3  size กุ้งเราไม่สบายๆกินกุ้งแล้วไม่
สบายอ่ะเรียกเรียกว่าแพ้กุ้งงี้ 5 ทราย
ครับหรือเรียกว่าแพ้อาหารทะเลทั้งหมดกิน
ไม่ได้ช้าใช่ใช่ครับอ่ะมีนักเรียนนัก
เรียนคนไหนแพ้อาหารทะเลบ้างครับนะถ้ามี
คีมในคอมเม้นให้หน่อยจะได้รู้ phd จะได้
รู้นักเรียนแพ้อาหารทะเล
โอเคอะมีแพะอาหารทะเลแล้วมีแพ้อะไรได้อีก
ครับมีอาหารอะไรที่กินแล้วแพ้ครับแพ้คัน
หรือว่าไอ้จู 5 มีไหมมีบางคน
เพียงดื่มนมไม่ได้ก็ดื่มนม 5 นี่ครับนม 5
นี้เป็นนมอ่ะอันนี้เป็นนมอะไรครับ
นมวัวนมวัวนี่มีวัวอยู่ตรงนี้วัวนมวัว
น้ำวัวหอยกินดื่มไม่ได้ดื่มนมวัวแล้วแผล
ใช่ไหมอ่าดื่มนมวัวแล้วไม่สบาย
ใช่คันด้วยคันไว้
อ่ะบางทีขั้น
เปียตีเห็นบางคนเวลากินนมวัวแล้วอะที่ตัว
ที่แขนด้วยนะอ้าที่
ยากและเดี๋ยวพี่เอติฮัดรูปคนโอเคหารูปภาพ
คนนี้แล้วก็มีอีมีจุดจุดตรงนี้อ่าใช่ครับ
เป็นคันคัน
เก่าๆใช่แบบเป็นแผนอมแพ้นมชายน้าขอคนกิน
แล้วเอาแบบนี้ไหมคะพี่อาร์ตี้อ้าใช่ๆเป็น
ผื่นเป็นปื้นๆแล้วก็จะคันคันอยู่
แบบนี้กินกินนมไม่ได้น้าๆที่แถนมไหมคะ
เฮียตี้ยังไม่แพ้ติดกินทุกอย่างกินได้อ้ะ
ให้กับไม่แพ้เขาเตรียมก็กินนมได้ไม่แท้
ไม่แพ้หนุ่มหน้าไม่แพ้นมวัวใช่ไหมไม่แพ้
นมวัวออกโอเค
ดีแล้วมีอะไรอีกครับที่กินแล้วแผลครับ
บางคนกิน
ถั่วไม่ได้ขอกินผัวไม่ได้อ้ะเฮียตี้เห็น
มีนมที่ทำมาจากถั่วใช่ไหมอันนี้เป็นนม
ถั่ว
หานมผัวอันนี้ถั่วอะไรครับเนี่ย
ถั่วเหลืองขอ
[เพลง]
แต่บางคนกินแล้วอาบหายใจไม่ออก
หาค่าหรอโอ๋โอ๋น่ากลัวนะกลัวกลัวมากเฮีย
ตี๋หายใจแม้
ใครไม่ออกนะ
น้องเรียนถั่วเหลือง
เตรียมไม่แพ้นมถั่วเหลืองออกเลียมกลิ่น
ได้ใช่ไหมกินได้เตรียมกินได้
อ้าเราน่ากินได้ไม่แพ้โอเคอ่ะมีอะไรอีก
ครับหอมเมื่อกี้น้องเรียนบอกว่ามีถั่ว
เพื่อตีเห็นถั่วมีหลายชนิดมากเลยหน้ามี
ครัว 5 เยอะเลยมีถั่วอะไรบ้างครับ
มีถั่วแดง R มีถั่วแดงตัวแดงอยู่นี่ครับ
นี่ถั่วแดงหน้าหอ S ถั่วแดงเป็นสีแดงแดง
แล้วอันนี่ถูกอะไร
ทำอะไรคะ
เฮลโลเฮียตีใหม่หรือ
ถั่วแดงใช่มั้ยอ๋อ
หัวแดงถั่วดำมีสีดำเรียกถั่วดำอ่ามีสีแดง
เรียกถั่วแดงอ๋อเอาแล้วอันนี่
นี้อันนี้ดิ
ถั่วสีเขียวเครียดหัวเขียวถั่วเขียว
เพื่อที่รู้แล้วถ้าอย่างนั้นให้เสร็จ
นี้ขึ้นที RE  Hack ถั่วอะไรครับ
กลัวสีเหลืองเขาเรียกถั่วเหลือง
กลัวเหลืองสีเหลืองอ่ะถั่วแดงสีแดง
หน้าถั่วเขียวสีเขียว
ดำ
สีดำหัวดำทำโอเคโอเคแล้ว
ไม่รู้จักสีอะไรครับไม่รู้จักขอ
ไม่รู้จักนักเรียนรู้จักถ่วงไหมคะอ๋ออ๋อ
ตัวนี้ตัวนี้นะที่อยู่ตัวนี้ผู้อะไรครับ
คั่วอะไรคะเฮียตี้ไม้รู้น้องเรียมไม่รู้
อ่านนักเรียนรู้ไหมครับถั่วอะไรห่า
บอกบอกคะเดียวกับพี่อาร์ตี้นะคะของใน
Comment ว่าพวก
หาโอเคมีถั่วแดงถั่วแดงถั่วเขียวถั่วดำ
ถั่วเหลือง
พี่คิดว่าอันนี้อันนี้ก็เป็นถั่วเหลืองนะ
อันนี้ถั่วเหลืองที่เอามาทำเอามาทำนมถั่ว
เหลืองนี่ใช่ค่ะเหลืองแต่ตรงนี้สี่ก็อาจ
จะเป็นสี
ขาวๆหน่อยเขาขาวๆเหลืองบ่นกัน 5 เป็นถั่ว
เหลืองอ๋อคิดว่าว่าเขาเอาเปลือกออก
ถั่วถั่วถั่ว
ที่พี่อาร์ตี้เห็นเป็นสีขาวอาหารมีเปลือก
อ๋ออ๋อเป็นเปลือกสีขาวข้างในสีเหลืองหรอ
คิดเดี๋ยวคิดว่าแบบนะนะฮะโอเค R  R ไม่
เป็นไรอ่ะแล้วอ่าน้องจากถั่วมีทัวร์เยอะ
แยะเลยที่กินแล้วแพ้นะครับหน้ามีคนที่แพ้
อะไรได้อีกครับ
อะไรนะมีเพียงตีเห็นมีรูปรูปที่เตรียมไว้
มีรูปนี้ครับเป็นอะไรนะเนี่ยเป็นดอกหอม
ออกมา High ดอกอะไรครับดอกเฮ้ยทิวหรอดอก
อะไรไม่ใช่ดอกอะไรครับ
เป็นดอกไม้อ่ะอ๋ออันนี้เป็นเกสรไหม
เกสรดอกไม้ดอกไม้มีดอกไม้
มีดอกไม้ดอกไม้
ที่ดอกไม้จะมีเกสรอ่าเฮียตี้เปลี่ยนสีประ
กาเกสรแบบนี้อีก
5 วันนี้นะมีเกสรนี่มีเกสรเคสอดเกสรดอก
ไม้ช่อดอกไม้ก็จะมีกลิ่นร้อยออกมา
เล็กกลิ่นอาเข้าจมูกก็
ใช่ไหมจ่า
บางคนแพ้เกสรดอกไม้แพ้เกสรดอกไม้ 5 นี่
เกสรดอกไม้เราก็จะจาม 3 ฮัดชิ่ว
ครับเราก็จะมีน้ำมูก
อ๋ออ๋อเวลาจานมาเวลาแพ้มีน้ำมูกเอ้อเห้ย
เปลี่ยนตัวอะไรครับเนี่ย
พึ่ง of ผึ้ง
ผึ้งผึ้งมามา
อยู่คุณน้ำหวานจากเกสรดอกไม้ก็ไม่แพ้พึ่ง
ไม่แพ้เกตุแสงปืนชอบชอบเกสรดอกไม้อ่าโอเค
น้องเรียมแผลไหมครับแพ้เกสรดอกไม้ไหม
เตรียมไม่แพ้มีสอนดอกเหมือนไม่แพ้อ่ะเฮีย
ตีก็ไม่แผลเมื่อ
ว่าคนบางคนอาบอยู่ใกล้อยู่ใกล้อยู่ใกล้ๆ
มั้งใกล้ดอกไม้ไม่ได้ไกลไม่ได้เพราะว่าแถ
ใช่ไหมชุด
แล้วก็หายใจไม่ออกหายใจไม่ออกไม่ออก
หายใจเข้า
หายใจออกไม่ได้ได้ไม่ได้อ๋อต้องเอาว่าเอา
ดอกไม่ออกเขาดอกไม้ออกไปหายใดไม่เคยไปขอ
ไปขอแพ้เดินทางเดินเล็กลายๆสังข์อ.แดงออก
ไป
หือว้าวต้องใส่ mad หรือเปล่าคะอ้าใส่แมส
The บนออกไปข้างนอกอาหา
ใช่ครับใช่
ว่าโอเคมีแพ้เกสรดอกไม้เมื่อกี้น้องเรียม
พูดถึงพูดถึงแพ้แพ้นี้
แพ้แมวนะครับ
แฮร์แมวหรอ
คนแนวสอนเฉพาะอ่าตองขนแมวตรงนี้ใช่ไหมนะ
ใช่ค่ะอาทิตย์เปลี่ยนสีปากกาเป็นสีแดงอ่ะ
ขนแมวตรงนี้ขนแมวแมวจะมีขนอยู่มีคนมีคน
น๊าอ๋อ
ก็แหมเพราะทำไมถึงแพ้ครับขนเข้าจมูกหรอ
เค้าจะหมดหา
คนเข้าจมูกค่าเข้าไปในจมูกใช่ไหม
คนเข้าจมูกแพ้จามเลยๆชิว
ขอสมแมวเข้าจมูกแท้
หนอโอเค ami แพ้อะไรบ้างนะครับวันนี้
กูมีแพ้อาหารทะเลแพ้อาหารทะเลกินไม่ได้
แพ้แพ้นะโอเคแล้วมีแพ้อะไรอีกครับ
แท้นมวัวแพ้นมวัวนะแล้วก็อันนี้แพ้นม
เหมือนกันแต่เป็นนมนมถั่วหัวน่านมถั่ว
เหลืองนะครับน้าอาราตะแพ้ถั่วหาแล้วก็มี
แพะ
แพ้เกสรดอกไม้สอนดอกไม้
ว้าวแล้วก็อันสุดท้ายสุดท้ายแพ้
ขนขนแมว
โอเคอ่านักเรียนมีใครมีใครแพ้อะไรบ้างไหม
ครับถ้ามีใครแพ้อะไรบอกเพียงตีบอกน้อง
เรียมในคอมเม้นให้หน่อยว่าแพ้อะไรเนื้อ
ใช่ค่ะที่ไม่แพ้ไม่แพ้เลยแล้วอ้ะก็ไม่แพ้
บอกบอกเราด้วยนะคะว่าเวลาที่เเท้รู้สึกมี
อาการจามให้คิวคิวหรือว่าคัน
ตามว่าขายใจไม่ออกหรออ๋อเวลาที่แพ้ใช่ไหม
หาอ่าโอเค
ด.ญ.อาอ้าวันนี้เราเรียนกันเรื่องแพ้
เดี๋ยวคราวหน้าเรากลับมาเรียนกันใหม่จะ
เป็นเรื่องอะไรเดี๋ยวคอยติดตามกันครับนว
นิเวลาเวลาหมดหมดเวลาแล้วหมดโดยไม่มาแล้ว
นะครับ 5 เดี๋ยว
เดี๋ยวเกลียดอีกับน้องเรียมไปก่อนลาไป
ก่อนแล้วเดี๋ยวคราวหน้ากลับมาเจอกันใหม่
ครับใจค่ะค่ะสวัสดีค่ะพี่โรงเรียนสวัสดี
ครับนักเรียนบ๊ายบายนักเรียนภาย